foreign Republican Governors sending
more migrants to democratic strongholds
as more migrants and drugs flow over our
open Southern border joining us now from
Texas when we're acting ice director Tom
Homan Tom thank you for taking time I
want to play for you a short interview I
did with a Venezuelan migrant named
wazir Khan who was on the bus Thursday
the Texas governor Greg Abbott sent
specifically to vice president Harris's
home in response to her comments on last
Sunday's Meet the Press where she said
the Border was Secure here is what the
migrant from Venezuela told me take a
listen
it's open not close your body is open
it's open because we enter we come in
free
no problem yeah we came illegally not
legal
Tom your reaction
well I actually saw that interview live
and I set the time that
Kamala Harris you know the the supposed
borders are she's 150 yards away in her
residence if she's really looking for
the root causes of this massive illegal
immigration she could simply walk down
where you were Griff and ask the same
question then she'd find out they're
coming because the board is open they
cross easily and they've been invited so
there you go but of course she's
ignoring it I thought it was a great
question I thought the the person you
talked to is honest I think Governor
Abbott's a genius for sending buses to
her residence because she's made this a
national conversation you've talked
about this for a couple years bill
malusion on the border this network's
only Network talking about it but what
he's done is get these Democratic Mayors
and vice president up in arms more
people more networks are talking about
so he created a national conversation
that will keep this issue on the front
pages who knew and you're right I've
been talking about this for years I've
traveled to the Panamanian jungle where
Venezuelan migrants cross the most
dangerous jungle on the planet I've
traveled 7 000 miles with multiple
migrant Caravans from Honduras to
Guatemala through the entirety of Mexico
to places like Eagle Pass who knew it
only took a couple of buses to vice
president Harris's house in a plane to
Martha's Vineyard to get the country to
start talking about it now let me just
show our viewers a little comparison
because I wanted to show this if you
compare Martha's Vineyard to Del Rio and
this is uh actually the the number of
encounters there nearly 50 000 in Del
Rio who has a population of just under
35 000 that's just in the month of July
and yet Martha's Vineyard which has a
population of 17 000 had 50 people and
yet people on Martha's Vineyard are
freaking out here is a sound bite of a
woman who is trying to help here's what
she said
at some point in time they have to move
into somewhere else right we we cannot
we don't have the services to take care
of 50 immigrants
um and we we certainly don't have
housing we're in a housing crisis a
crisis Tom
if you don't know what the crisis is you
want to see a crisis she needs to go on
the southern border and you got you know
you got the mayor of Chicago made a
statement that it was racist and and
other people say human trafficking you
know what if in in several said this is
hate it is it is inhumane if they want
to see inhumane conditions go down the
southern border we have over 1300 dead
migrants died on U.S sources Joe Biden
become president you have well over a
hundred thousand Americans dying to
fentanyl overdose since Joe Biden become
president if you want to see if you want
to see a a 31 of women making this
journey get sexually assaulted children
are drowning in the river so if you want
to talk about healing Humanity go to the
border so those Mayors I say welcome to
the crisis every State's a border state
now and we're not even talking about the
fentanyl that's making every town city
and state because it's open border
finding they're speaking up and maybe
they'll care if they don't care about
illegal immigration then care about the
fentanyl overdoses care about the open
border that's going to attract no one
suspected terrorists come this country
do us harm care about the money women
they get sexually assaulted in the sex
trafficking of women and children maybe
you'll start caring now that you
actually see this in your front on your
front door well Tom California's
governor
Governor is about the
situation he wants Governors Avenue
DeSantis charged with kidnapping
well let's open that can of worms
Governor Newsom because you have a
sanctuary State you you conceal and
harbor illegal aliens in your jails
don't get Vice access to it Title VII
the United States code says that's
harboring concealing that's a felony
let's talk about the inducement and
encouragement of illegal immigration
when you when you promise free health
care and you promised driver's license
you promise you don't work with us you
promised that ice I don't have access to
your jails when you promised criminal
aliens be released back to the street is
that not inducing and encouraging
illegal immigration which is also
friendly so Governor Gavin Newsom
reviewed title eight United States code
1324. I think you will find yourself in
trouble yourself so if you want to open
this can of worms let's go
former acting ice director and Fox's
contributor Tom home and Tom thank you
for taking time have a great weekend sir
thanks for having me Griff I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis